Lindsay Levin: Welcome,
we're excited to have you here,
and one of the things we're very keen
to do with Countdown
is to follow up on stuff
and find out how our promises fare.
And I know that Maersk,
I believe it's correct to say
that your greenhouse gas emissions,
as a global business,
are greater than that of Denmark,
where you're based.
So you're a big part of the challenge.
So tell us, how's it going?
Morten Bo Christiansen:
Thanks for having us.
And yeah, so we have this dream or vision
of decarbonizing our heavy-emitting
business by 2040,
so over the next 17 years.
And I think some find that
almost ridiculously ambitious. (Laughs)
We find it quite exciting.
And what is even more exciting
is that we're actually starting to do it,
we're actually part
of making the dream come true
and implementing solutions
in our business.
And let me just share some facts with you.
So over the last two years,
we have ordered 25 container ships
that can sail on green methanol,
which is our choice of green fuel.
It's a fuel that can be made
from either renewable electricity
or sustainable biomass.
19 of those are being
produced as we speak.
The first one, we took delivery
of three days ago,
so it's happening.
We also just announced the first retrofit
of an existing oil vessel
that can, in the future,
also burn green methanol
so we can learn how to do that.
On the land side,
we are building green warehouses,
we are electrifying our terminals.
We have 425 heavy-duty electric trucks
coming into our US market,
58 already deployed,
some of which actually just across
Lake Michigan, in Chicago.
We have 25 coming into Germany.
So, you know, lots and lots
of things happening
to actually make that a dream come true
that Jim spoke about two years ago.
LL: So, progress. This is progress?
MBC: Yeah, and it better be.
Global logistics account
for 11 percent of all emissions,
so all the trucks and ships and planes
and warehouses and ports.
So we have work to do.
LL: So tell us about this first new ship.
MBC: I can do better than telling,
I can actually show you.
I think we have a video of it.
There it is.
So this is not a rendering,
this is real steel.
And we took delivery of this ship Sunday,
and next Sunday,
it's going to do the first bunkering
of green methanol
in Ulsan, in South Korea.
Then, she's going to head out
with our well-trained Maersk crew
to set out for Shanghai, to pick up cargo.
She's going to stop over in Singapore,
in Port Said,
and in Rotterdam,
to pick up more green methanol,
because she has to make it
halfway around the world
to arrive in Copenhagen
on September 13th for name-giving.
And then, she will be deployed
in the Baltic Sea for operation.
LL: I can see we've got
a beautiful map of that route.
MBC: Yeah, and if I can --
This is just one ship, right?
And, for those who know container ships,
this is actually a rather small one.
But that's really not the point here.
I think the point
is that this thing is real, right?
It's happening.
And not least, it is the first of many.
We hear a lot of talk
about exponential change,
and how we need that.
And I'll give you
some exponential data points.
So three years ago,
there were none of these ships on order,
not a single one.
Two years ago, there was one.
That one -- oh, sorry, this one. (Laughs)
One year ago, there was 23;
19 of those were ours.
Today, we have
120 of these ships on order.
There are now five
major container carriers
who have started ordering these ships,
and a couple of feeder
providers as well.
So that's exponential change,
but I think that's exactly what we need
to shift this industry.
LL: Yeah.
(Applause)
LL: And there’s kind
of a chicken-and-egg problem.
You need the fuel,
the ship, the ship design.
Are you breaking away from this?
Where do you start -- chicken and egg?
MBC: Yeah, I think the chicken
has met the egg,
or whether it's the egg
that met the chicken? (Laughs)
I mean, this is a supply challenge, right?
We need to scale production
of green methanol, because it’s important.
It needs to be green methanol,
not the conventional methanol
made from fossil fuels.
And that really is a challenge.
Just to put that,
a bit, into perspective --
we have 740 ships at Maersk.
If all of those were to sail
on so-called e-methanol,
so methanol made
from renewable electricity,
we would need somewhere
between five and six percent
of all wind and solar produced today
in the entire world.
LL: Just for your business?
MBC: Yes.
MBC: So I think that the magnitude of this
is almost mind-blowing.
But I think that's just
all the more reason to get started.
LL: So that scale, that magnitude,
very daunting --
is that holding people back,
different players in the industry?
It's just too much?
MBC: I think there's, of course,
the enormity of the challenge,
I think that goes for any part
of decarbonization, right?
But I think, for shipping, particularly,
there’s a lot of uncertainty around
what’s the winning technology, right?
Because there's this green methanol,
that's one solution.
You have green ammonia,
you have green methane,
you have liquified hydrogen,
electrification, even nuclear.
So there's this fear, I think,
of making the wrong bet
or getting it wrong, somehow.
Of course, in an ideal world,
we would spend a decade figuring out
all the pros and cons
and what is best.
But we need to address
this problem now, right?
And honestly, there is no
magic bullet here.
All these solutions can work,
I think they will work.
They all have their pros and cons.
But we just need to get on with it.
LL: And you've chosen methanol
as your fuel of choice.
Why is that?
MBC: It's very simple --
it works, and it works now.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
LL: It works, it works now,
and these green fuels
are still more expensive,
because we've got to build up the volume.
Talk to us a little bit
about the price issues.
MBC: It almost sounds too easy, right?
And it really isn't,
because one of the big challenges
is, of course, that these fuels
are more expensive.
So if we take fuel
at the current oil price,
green methanol can easily be twice,
even three times the price.
So that's of course quite a bit.
And of course, somebody
needs to pay the bill.
Who needs to pick up that bill?
At the end of the day,
I guess it's all of us, as consumers,
because it’s our consumption
that creates the emissions.
And the interesting thing
is, when you check it
through the value chain,
it really dilutes.
So if you double up the fuel price,
that sounds crazy, right?
Well, that means the freight rate
goes up 10 to 15 percent.
And if you take a pair of shoes
or an item like that,
that's, like, five cents.
And there's actually
a quite interesting study
by the Boston Consulting Group
that shows that most consumer products
can be made with a net-zero footprint,
so no emissions in production,
at a cost of somewhere
between one and four percent.
So that's really
what we are talking about --
LL: So that doesn't sound too bad.
MBC: No, I think many of us
could afford that, right?
I mean, it's one year's inflation,
it's really what it is.
But the problem is that,
if all the cost gets stuck
at one place in the value chain,
then things don't move, right?
If you're a fuel producer,
and you're producing a product
that is two or three times
the price of your fossil competitor,
few would dare do that,
and nobody would get
any financing for it, right?
So these fuel producers,
they look to the shipowners
to make long-term offtake agreements,
and we do that.
I mean, last year at Maersk,
we spent eight billion dollars on fuel,
so doubling or tripling that,
that’s a pretty scary outcome.
So we need to figure out
how we can then turn to our customers,
and have them pay a green premium,
and they do.
So I think that's really
what we need to do,
we need to get these partnerships
across the value chain
so that we stand together
and we just de-risk the thing.
Because when you de-risk, speed goes up.
And what we have done so far
is we have talked to a lot of developers,
we have signed up for the ship
that we just saw,
10 years worth of fuel for that one.
And for the other ones,
we have around 30 percent
on letters of intent
for our expected consumption by 2030.
So that's how we are trying to lean out
and lend our balance sheet.
LL: So you're giving confidence
to the value chain.
MBC: We're basically taking out
commercial risk on these projects.
And then we, of course,
need to turn to our customers
to figure out how they can
either pass that onto us as consumers
or somehow create value from that.
That's really the challenge we have.
LL: Morten, thank you very much.
Great to listen to you,
and we wish you well
with the rest of the journey.
MBC: Thank you.
LL: Thank you very much.